e
réseau de la santé est énorme.
Marie Isabelle Rochon.- Ici, vo,
puis ça, ce sont des métastases.
- Depuis les deux dernières
années, le Dr Martin Champagne
observe de plus en plus
de patients avec des cancers
avancés. Un des impacts
de la pandémie.
Dr MARTIN CHAMPAGNE, président,
Ass. médecins hémato.-onco., Qc
- On n'arrive pas à combler
les retards, par exemple,
en endoscopie pour
les coloscopies.
- Le défi est d'assurer
l'accessibilité aux soins.
Parce qu'en plus des retards
liés à la pandémie, un plus
grand nombre de personnes
vivent avec le cance
- Et je ne suis pas certain
qu'on y soit prêts, pour faire
face à cette demande accrue-là
qu'on peut anticiper.
Il y a toujours des délais
pour avoir accès aux examens
radiologiques, donc il faut
trouver des portes d'entrée
rapides, dans le système,
pour que vous puissiez entrer
dans le système et être pris,
donc, en charge rapidement.
- La Société canadienne
du cancer estime qu'en 2022,
1,5 million de Canadiens
ont ou ont eu la maladie.
En 2012, 193 000 personnes
avaient reçu un diagnostic
de cancer.
En 2022, ce nombre était
de 233 900 personnes.
JEAN-MICHEL BILLETTE, chef,
stat. cancer, Statistique Canada
- Il y a toujours plus de cas
diagnostiqués, parce que
la population vieillit.
r r r r r est au premier chef
une maladie chronique qui est
associée avec le vieillissement
de la population.
Et la population continuede cro.
DAVID RAYNAUD, équipe Défense
int. public, Société can-. cancr
- Donc, il faut surtout,
dans les réflexions qu'on a,
notamment avec le plan Dubé,
la réforme de la santé
au Québec, réfléchir à ça :
comment est-ce qu'on va adresser
cette augmentation de cancer
qui s'en vient à l'avenir?
- Une des clés : metcececececent
sur le dépistage.
- On n'investit probablement pas
suffisamment dans la prévention,
l'enseignement, donc, préventif,
le dépistage précoce.
Il existe des possibilités de
dépister pour le cancer du col,
pour le cancer du poumon,
pour le cancer de la prostate,
mais présentement, il n'y a pas
de balises claires,
de programmes instaurés
qui ciblent des populations
à risque.
- Des programmes de dépistage
qui devraient être accessibles
et automatiques pour
une certaine partie
de la population.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa